hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be taking a look at some of the
Lesser well-known Mysteries surrounding
the castle and grounds of Hogwarts
School but what's truly unique about
today's video is that we'll be looking
at this topic with visual accompaniment
from the much anticipated Harry Potter
game Hogwarts Legacy which is now
available on PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
S and PC but before we get started I
want to say a big thank you to Warner
Brothers games for sponsoring this video
and making all of this possible Hogwarts
Legacy dives into the Wizarding World in
a time period that we've never seen
before the 1800s and it's through this
game that Harry Potter fans will be able
to navigate The Wizarding World We love
so much through a bit of a different
lens in Hogwarts Legacy our character
will experience the life of a Hogwarts
student first hand living the unwritten
and embarking on a dangerous journey to
uncover a massive hidden truth of the
1800s Wizarding World developed by
Avalanche software and published by
Warner Bros games and the port key games
label Hogwarts Legacy introduces an
original story that gives us the freedom
to embark on our own Wizarding World
adventure Paving our own path and
uncovering new territory all in the
pursuit of uncovering this magical
world's hidden truth but until you play
the game this hidden truth is going to
remain a mystery which brings us back to
the topic of today's video Mysteries
particularly Mysteries pertaining to the
Hogwarts Castle Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry was founded
sometime in the 10th Century by four of
the greatest witches and wizards of the
time they were of course godric
Gryffindor Rowena Ravenclaw Helga
hufflebuff and Salazar Slytherin you'll
no doubt recognize each of these names
as the sources of the great houses
within Hogwarts however in addition to
these four it is also believed that
there may have been a fifth wizard
involved in the construction of the
castle the man responsible for the
design and building of the great school
only known as the architect in fact this
unnamed architect could be the reason
that there are so many Mysteries and
secrets abounding throughout the castle
in terms of its architectural structure
the school is much like any Castle it is
said to have around 24 Towers in all
with 12 larger more prominent ones and
12 smaller lesser known Towers the
astronomy Tower which was the site of
Headmaster Albus Dumbledore's death is
the tallest of the towers whereas The
Dark Tower on the seventh floor is among
the most mysterious the castle is seven
stories tall with approximately 142
staircases within according to
Dumbledore there was neither a living
nor dead soul in the world who knew all
the secrets of the castle so with that
in mind let's get to the Mysteries that
we'll be unveiling today number one the
location of course we know that Hogwarts
is somewhere in Scotland but it would
appear that no one ever discusses the
exact location the reason for this is
that the castle was placed under many
spells and enchantments by the founders
in an effort to ward off unfriendly
Muggles which is why someone without
magic only sees ruins and signs
deterring them from entering as you can
imagine the 10th century and the castle
was founded was not the best time to be
a witch or wizard this is likely why the
location is unplausable meaning that it
cannot be identified or pinpointed on a
map this may also explain why the
children are not dropped off directly at
the castle but rather are shuttled in by
the Hogwarts Express to hogsmeade it's
also worth noting that witches and
wizards are unable to operate or
disapparate within Hogwarts in addition
to a layer of protection for the
students could this simply be because no
one knows its exact coordinates 2. the
castle appears to be alive and sentient
this mystery is a bit of a tricky one to
explain because of course there are many
enchantments and charms placed upon and
within the castle these spells in
themselves do nothing to prove that
Hogwarts Castle is actually alive for
example the Great Hall showcases a few
of these wonderful charms none of which
prove sentience the ceiling mirrors the
sky above and the tables tend to change
their order and Arrangements there's
also the bit of fun to be had by way of
the charm at the entrance for
hufflepuff's common room here you must
tap a specific Barrel in a particular
way in order to gain admittance if you
get it wrong you get soaked in vinegar
but some of the enchantments seem to be
more like active choices made by the
castle itself the most obvious example
would be the staircases and how they
move at will but don't you find it odd
that they always seem to choose the
perfect moment when a student often a
first year is climbing them could this
perhaps be the stairs playing a joke
number three there are more secret
passages in Hidden rooms than we know
it's fairly safe to say that the secret
passages and hidden rooms that we know
of only scratch the surface of what's
concealed within the hallowed Halls of
Hogwarts what we do know is that there
are eight secret passages that lead in
and out of Hogwarts that are mentioned
throughout the series only seven of
these were shown on the Marauders map
including one that you caved in the one
under the Whomping Willow and the one
under the statue of the humpbacked witch
the eighth was later created by Draco
Malfoy through the room of requirement
speaking of the room of requirement can
hardly be classified as a mystery but
have you heard of the Hidden room known
as the room of rewards this is yet
another secret space at Hogwarts which
apparently records students
accomplishments the entrance can be
found the grand staircase behind a
portrait of vindictus Viridian 4. there
is a book of admittance and quill of
acceptance apparently the only system of
admittance Hogwarts has ever used is an
ancient magical book and a quill known
as the book of admittance and the quill
of acceptance The Story Goes that if the
quill has written a child's name in the
book they are sent a letter of
acceptance to the school at the age of
11. no questions asked every birth of a
magical child or muggle child who shows
magical ability is said to be recorded
into the book by the quill the book and
quill are strictly kept within a locked
Tower of Hogwarts the book is bound by
the hide of a black dragon and evidently
no human has laid hands on it since the
four founders of Hogwarts placed it
there 5. the school motto as you may
recall in some of my previous videos the
motto for Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry is a rather confounding one
the motto
is Latin for never tickle a sleeping
Dragon of course to a muggle who is used
to school mottos being quite prestigious
and let's admit a little bit stuffy this
seems a rather odd saying for such a
world-renowned school however it does
seem ever so fitting that Hogwarts motto
would be humorous but practical and with
that we've come to the end of another
video thanks again to Warner Brothers
games for sponsoring this video and be
sure to check out Hogwarts Legacy now
available on PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
S and PC to pick up a copy use my link
in the description box below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
thank you